non
nous
la moto compte pour 45 % mais le pilote
comptent pour 55 % pour - le pilote
c'est tout koné d'audit avec 12 titres
remportés entre championnats nationaux
et arc-en-ciel la saison 1956 représente
un record absolu de victoires obtenues
en une seule saison
pour le pilote plus on a deux virages et
de difficulté plus on s'engage dans la
recherche du rendement maximum
on a toujours l'objectif du record on
est obsédé par deux critères la
mécanique et le temps
mécanique les tpg
la caricature
par les temps affirmations du coup elle
la victoire la plus remarquable parmi
tout est sûrement celle du titre mondial
des 500 remportées par john surtees
un succès qui marque l'entrée de la
marque mv dans le livre d'or de la
catégorie reine
je participais aux courses avec la 350
cm cube et la 500 centimètres cubes
mais le conte me fier essayé aussi là
deux cent cinquante centimètres cube
pour les courses anglaises dans le but
de m'habituer aux motos mv agusta
finalement on était sur le point de
trouver un accord quand le compte me dit
un moment s'il te plaît une femme entre
a habillé de noir une voilette noire sur
la tête elle se rapprocha du comté à lui
murmura quelque chose à l'oreille puis
elle me regarda est sorti
un des buts à 1 2
monsieur car anonyme dit c'était la
comtesse elle est venue donner son
approbation pourtant entré dans la
famille agusta c'est après avoir été
acceptée par la famille agusta qui a
commencé le travail du 1
sorti ça a été un grand coureur
il est arrivé chez mv après d'autres
pilotes
il était un des plus précis nous nous
sommes mis d'accord au départ
moi je m'occupais du moteur et lui il
s'occupait du cadre moi je préparais la
moto pour les expos pour ce qui
concernait la carburation les
anticipations etc
puis il s'occupait personnellement de la
régulation de l'huile les amortisseurs
le rapport avec la moto doit être
spécial
mais bien évidemment aujourd'hui les
circuits en changer je me suis amusé à
courir sur les circuits anciens c'était
des circuits fantastique mais
aujourd'hui le développement de la
technologie bien que positifs pourraient
avoir des conséquences négatives comme
celles de gommer la différence subtile
entre un champion et un grand champion
je crois que la différence vient de
l'homme et pas de la technologie
cependant je suis convaincu que
l'amélioration constante doit être
recherchée et qu'on ne peut pas se
soustraire aux progrès de la technologie
ce qui pourtant me rend triste sont les
changements structuraux voir les pilotes
réussir a été fantastique
ainsi que d'assister à leur passage de
la 125 centimètres cubes à la 250 cm
cube aujourd'hui l'époque des 250 est
fini et je le regrette
mais le trio milles entre 1958 et 1960
lusine de cascina cost a gagné 1,63
course sur 76 surtout grâce à la forme
physique des pilotes comme sorti ce
ougna lee provini et michael good
permettez à passer en apprend beaucoup
de spectateurs passionnés de motos et
michael good a été le plus grand
champion de toute l'histoire du sport
motocycliste si sa capacité à donner
toujours le maximum quel que soit les
chances de gagner l'a rendu légendaire
surnommé mike the bike
le pilote anglais décrocha neuf titres
du mondial et quattro parmi ceux-ci
quatre furent compte y ait un seul sur
la mv agusta 500 de 1962 à 1965
à l'affiner dhayani c'est ça la fin des
années 60 dans le panorama du
motocyclisme un très bon pilote de
mantoue angelo bergame en ti et merchat
il entra dans l'équipe en 1970 et
démontra dès le début sa grande classe
bien et quand il fut confirmé pour la
saison 1971 obtenant de très bons
résultats surtout sur les circuits en
ville
malheureusement une chute pendant une
course sur le circuit de riccione sous
un orage lui fut fatal
c'était un pilote remarquable d un homme
bien
à partir du moment où il a commencé à
concourir
l'esprit de chevalerie le sens de
l'honneur et la courtoisie furent ses
qualités premières
man
la fin de cette décennie fut placée sous
le signe des nouvelles technologies mais
tony glanant une amélioration nette des
performances et de la façon de conduire
pour ce qui est des propulseurs la mv
atténue la puissance de 70 chevaux pour
la 500 et de 45 pour l'a350
pour moi la meilleure dans l'absolu et
l'a350 4 cylindres une moto que j'ai
essayé personnellement et que j'estime
être la plus performante de toutes les
emp et sous tous les angles
il la nouvelle décennie commence à sous
la suprématie du duo mv agusta qui
réussit un beau doublé arc-en-ciel 350
500 en 1970 71 et 72
mon rêve était de participer aux grands
championnats du monde
la morinie n'y participait pas et la mv
agusta cette grande marque avait un
trois cylindres près le comte agosta
voulait un italien pour la piloter sur
les pistes moi je me sentais d'attac
ainsi je commençais le championnat du
monde le conte à ghosta imagina une
trois cylindres une moto basse et
maniable à cette époque là il se
trouvait à venise on a transporté la
moto jusqu'à venise pour la lui montrer
et finalement le conte à 10 pour cette
manteau je veux un pilote italien
il était déjà à peu près 18 19 heures
mais le compte 10 avant minuit
tu dois me dire le nom du pilote italien
qui courra avec cette moto je regardais
dans mon agenda et jeu sorti le nom de
agostini manie me téléphona et il me dit
que le comte agusta voulait me voir et
je devais me présenter le jour suivant à
17 heures moi j'avais tellement peur
d'arriver en retard que je me suis
présenté à 16h30
j'ai traversé ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque les porteurs de cascina cost et
je m'installais dans un bureau pour
attendre le compte 18 heures arriva à 19
heures le compte ne m'avait pas encore
reçu je rester là à regarder les
employés qui évolue et d'un bureau à
l'autre avec plein de papiers sous leurs
bras
20h j'arrêtais quelqu'un pour lui dire
que j'attendais le compte depuis trois
heures et on me répondit vous ne devez
pas vous inquiéter le compte à augusta a
beaucoup de choses à faire
je voulais partir mais je savais qu'une
occasion pareille
celle de pouvoir rencontrer le comtat
gust ne se produirait pas tous les jours
finalement il m'a reçue à 22h
agostini et est un très bon pilote et
selon moi il a été un des plus grands
champions du monde il était très précis
dans la préparation de sa moto pour les
compétitions
parfois quand ils ne connaissaient pas
la piste le soir il faisait un tour pour
essayer la boîte de vitesses
il se mettait au lit avec ses papiers
plein de schéma il commençait à dire ici
on doit mettre un premier temps ici un
second temps fait d'une certaine manière
un troisième temps fait d'une autre
façon encore je me souviens d'une année
à sa lisbourg à 23h j'aime plagnet d'un
moteur qui ne fonctionnait pas comme je
voulais les mécaniciens ont commencé à
démonter la moto ils ont terminé à 5h à
7h on était sur la piste
quel effort cet après midi là je leur ai
offert la victoire
cette victoire d'agostini a été un
moment inoubliable incomparable
agos 172 agostini doit faire face à une
concurrence acharnée dans le leader et
jarno saarinen pilotant les deux temps
yamaha sifflante
alors on a commencé à lutter contre les
japonais c'était l'europe contre le
japon agostini mv dont toute l'italie
contre le japon
les japonais n'avaient pas encore
atteint le niveau de technologie que mv
agusta avait à cette époque là par
exemple la boîte de vitesses extractible
qui pour nous était si simple
les japonais ne la connaissais pas pour
changer de boîte de vitesses il leur
fallait démonter tout le moteur
la mv agusta avait déjà une boîte de
vitesses extractible et ça représentait
un grand avantage
entre un tour et l'autre on pouvait la
changer a tandis que les japonais
devaient attendre le soir pour pouvoir
ouvrir le moteur même discours pour ce
qui concerne le type de matériaux
utilisés ils amv utiliser le titane pour
les engrenages le pot d'échappement et
le cadre les japonais n'utilisait pas ce
type de matériau quand on démontait une
moto mv agusta si on la comparait à une
moto japonaise franchement les japonais
avaient un niveau de qualité nettement
inférieur mv agusta atteignait un niveau
de qualité qui était très supérieure
probablement grâce au passé de la
société dans le monde de l'aéronautique
la mv agusta mv agusta réagi en
fabriquant une 4 cylindres 350 gagnante
plus maniable et performante que la
précédente
en 1973 la montée des moteurs 2 temps
même dans la catégorie reine devient
indéniable et mv agusta ce vite obligé
de répondre par une nouvelle évolution
de sa 4 cylindres 500 qui permet à phil
read de gagner le titre arc en ciel dans
la catégorie inférieure l'arc en ciel
est remporté par giacomo agostini qui à
la fin de la saison rend officiel son
passage chez yamaha